ever since the incident which one bakery
where I got a model bringing beads into
the mix this is a foursome to be
reckoned with
squad calls [ __ ] bomb on your tire I
believe every hard are we open this we
are joined by celebrity guest beings
hard I was like who's keeper I am
resurrected a game that we played on the
grace Helbig show on e called
a boyfriend I thought it'd be really fun
to play with mamrie and Tyler because I
feel like you guys might know a lot
about both or neither of those things
safe sex
I'm in the classical films and unsafe
sex I'm gonna list off a a title and
they have to ring in and how do we bring
it slightly last time we had shakers I
know
well yeah I want to find from oh you
guys have to create your buzzer noises
but oh that's very similar to my classic
noise oh you guys have to choose a very
short boyband lyric as your ringing
phrase my my my my just a bunch I buy I
think she meant fake 100h that's the
heart dance
great answer what's your point man um
that's great by the end of this game the
person that is the loser gets drawn on
by the winner
yeah boyband facial hair goods always a
certain member of a boy band that has
very very specific unflattering facial
here we go
you guys both remember your buzzer
noises um ship out that's my heart
wait hot what is it a question I was
giving you a name yeah you have
oh hey Andrea they say if it's a condom
brand or a boy ban on them it's a boy
band
yeah Code Red remember you have negative
one negative one
come on oh oh [ __ ] that's a condom oh no
is a condom no because you wrap it up -
you should be come on oh I know
honestly become oh no I'm a good boy in
the act
ouch that's my heart boy band yeah
memory is zero points cuz she caught
herself up and Tyler has won a flight um
condom yeah for sure God we gotta be
other defenders we go I might even
regional name seven singles set yeah
better believe girl don't lie to me my
heart my life my art my strife biceps
about my Korean short attack that's my
heart oh ah that's a boy
hey guys this is editing grace right now
in editing this video I realized that I
liked mamrie here and actually blue is
the name of a boy band look your photo
yeah my bad no one tell mamrie no she's
gone
okay ready last couple note Oh let's get
you banned it's a boy it's a boy bad
yeah you put it on top of a king now
this has been really fun we're gonna
pretend all the points I haven't
mattered at all on this is the final
final question that determines it all
another bad creation um no thank you
you've gotta be a boy banner Christian
woman can I steal if I name three songs
by them
I have no thing to know oh well I'm sure
I missed the bus she was the girl on the
feather hat and I'd like to get to know
her better
you guys remember at the playground you
know I got the point
I know but I feel like maybe really
still can't over steel the day it's
gonna happen as you both get an
opportunity to draw a boyband facial
hair on each other of yourself
this is the weirdest therapy session
these are the final products take a look
at your beautiful faces
relax your face thank you guys for
participating even though it's happening
on my face right now none of us do my
face is really out of focus we're
participating in condom brand or boyband
go subscribe to Tyler we shot a video
over there and subscribe to mamrie they
shot a hilarious video and also they
subjected themselves to this kind of
treatment so friendship I don't know you
can see it I can't even see it what were
you doing there you go can I drink of
course you can you're home already
you're fine would you call me home
already I have no idea